if you're hiking pretty much anywhere in
the US this is one sound you don't want
to hear the warning of a rattlesnake now
just because the rattlesnakes tail
sounds like a built-in maraca doesn't
mean it works like one there are no
beads rattling about in here so what's
really going on inside if you opened up
a rattlesnakes rattle and shook it
absolutely nothing would fall out after
all
so rattlesnake rattles are Hollow that's
herpetologist Tim Colston
he says the secret to that rattling
sound comes from the shell itself it's
made of keratin the same hard substance
as your fingernails the keratin is
arranged in a chain of interlocking
rings which are hooked together by tiny
grooves along their edge now watch what
happens to those rings when Colston
shakes the rattle when ever I shake them
very fast they bump together producing
the sound because the rattle is hollow
inside sound waves can bounce off the
walls and echo the same way shouting in
a cave amplifies the sound and the
bigger the cave or hollow rings in this
case the more amplification so it's a
louder the rattle but a big hollow
chamber can't get the job done on its
own that's where the tail muscles come
in rattlesnakes are equipped with three
powerful shaker muscles at the base of
their spine those can contract so fast
they vibrate the rattle up to 90 times a
second for comparison the human eye
blinks 15 to 20 times a minute by
vibrating so quickly the rattle makes a
sound that hits between these specific
frequencies and it just so happens that
that range is best heard by mammals it
turns out that tail is custom designed
to make predators like bears raccoons
and weasels listen up unfortunately
snake --let's
yes that's what baby snakes are called
don't have this warning signal whenever
a rattlesnake is born it just has a
single button
it looks similar to the one I don't know
if you can see that's on the end here
without a second button to clack against
the baby rattle can't make any noise but
every time they shed their skin they add
another button to the base of the rattle
which grows into the segment above sort
of like the structure of a Russian
stacking doll the rattle will keep
growing until snap just like your
fingernails those rattles are pretty
fragile and they can break off if they
get too long in fact the rattles rarely
make it past eight to ten rings before
snapping off luckily snakes shed their
entire lives so the rattle will grow
back good as new
which is good news for you hikers
because that handy tail can mean the
difference between an exciting day on
the trail and a painful trip to the
hospital
[Music]